alors que 20 millions de tonnes de
céréales sont toujours bloqués dans les
silos ukrainien le président russe
vladimir poutine a évoqué des avancées
sur les exportations après une rencontre
avec son homologue turc un petit peu
plus tôt aujourd'hui entre-temps des
producteurs agricoles de l'est du canada
qui importe de l'engrais russe déplore
l'imposition de tarifs douaniers de 35%
les producteurs demandent à ottawa de
les indemniser rapidement et de corriger
la situation avec nos ghislain gervais
les présidents du groupe coopératif
soyaux et producteurs agricoles on sort
monsieur gervais
qu'est ce que vous demandez exactement
au gouvernement fédéral
on demande on se joint une coalition
d'organisations agricoles et
d'importateurs d'engrais pour demander
une indemnisation de la part du
gouvernement fédéral pour les posteurs
agricole qui subissent et inconvénients
des tarifs faut savoir que c'est une
particularité c'est seulement que les
pasteurs de l'est du canada qui sont
peut être impacté présente un prometteur
de 35% sous l'empiré russe et ce même si
la grève était commandée avant
l'extinction du 2 mars dernier et donc
fallu payer d'être terry de 35% sur ses
commandants grello même si steve été
commandé à l'automne dernier mais
pourquoi justement le tarif est imposé
après c'est parce que l'engrais c'est
long avant de le recevoir c'est ça il y
en a juste il transporte vous savez que
dans les faits ils à l'engrais est
arrivé dans la voie maritime du saint
laurent ces six fermé pendant les vols
grâce à la logistique de transport on
reçoit les propriétaires et lorsque l'on
aperçoit dans les bateaux les engrais
est un acte est encore un des pays
voisins la russie ce qui est en soi que
les tarifs ont été imposées et
malheureusement se retrouver cette
situation d'aujourd'hui puisque
traditionn où poussent des menteurs des
posteurs et une situation déplorable oui
on dit que c'est 85 90 % des engrais
utilisés en atlantique qui proviennent
de la russie au québec ça ressemble à
quoi
moi je vous dirais que c'est dans ces
zones un peu plus de notre côté sur yuko
coopératif soit près de 400 mille tonnes
d'engrais russe qu'on n'est pas chaque
année pour l'instruction dans l'est du
canada on est loin des petits porteurs
ce qu'on déplore aussi c'est de la façon
qu'ils étaient riches ont été posées une
décision qui était prise sans
consultation et sans considération les
impacts et présentent pas les
infractions les agriculteurs de liste
qu'on adopte les subissent et non la
russie est ce qu'il existe des
alternatives monsieur gervais est ce que
vous êtes obligés de continuer de vous
approvisionner en russie et certains
alternative qui s'offre à nous mais
c'est toujours une question de
compétitivité ou ces deux qualités au
niveau des engrais la logistique des
transports à savoir à quel moment ce
qu'on commande d'un bateau dans agréé sa
livraison s'il ya deux mois environ sur
100 jours amende à voir la disponibilité
des produits et l'engrais qui
proviendraient d'ailleurs je pense à
l'ouest canadien par exemple où on en
produit est ce que lui aussi coûte plus
cher
du côté de l'ouest canadien où il
désigne des mains de production l'enjeu
qu'on assure le transport pour l'amener
dans l'est du pays le seul transport
possible c'est via le train ce qui fait
en sorte que c'est agréable on n'est pas
compétitif et aussi des besoins dans les
pays dans l'ouest pays vous dirai ce
conduit la grèce ou d'élaborer une
personne à dungu de l'ouest le nord est
américain est ce que ça peut aller
jusqu'à jusqu'à menacer
l'approvisionnement c'est à dire est ce
que vous allez manquer d'engrais pour
les semis d'automne par exemple c'est un
peu ce qu'on demande aussi dans la
démarche confie ce parce que plus un
enfant n'est pas de prévisibilité quant
à la prochaine saison culture les
décisions d'approvisionnement se font
présentement leurs propres commandes et
on reproche ce dès la commande d'anglais
prisches présent faire prochainement et
de l'enjeu qu'on vit présentement c'est
que nous donne un côté on a déjà déclaré
plusieurs provisionnés en engrais de
relance de la russie c'est pas le cas de
tous nos compétiteurs est présentement
il ya des fabricants russes qui
interprétait du téléphone téléphone aux
différents importateurs pour dire
assumer une part des artistes et à
comment gouvernement de se brancher de
ce côté-là d'offrir une visibilité pour
l'accrocher sur ce qu'on peut faire et
ne pas faire qu'est ce qui ne vous
répond le ministère de l'agriculture est
ce qu'on vous est-ce qu'on vous fait
miroiter la possibilité de corriger la
situation est ce qu'on pourrait faire
une exception pour les engrais russe on
n'a pas de visibilité présentement sur
ce terrain là on a des communications
liens avec eux ou s'il faut savoir que
le canada est le seul pays du g7 avoir
imposé des engrais et fertilisants faut
savoir que présentement on parle d'une
pénurie alimentaire on sait que la
position alimentaire mondial est
perturbée alors qu'à côté on aurait
entendu les gens vous pouvez me mentir
on avait besoin de poster agricole que
la canada un rôle à jouer pour atténuer
les impacts potentiels des pénuries
alimentaires et de l'autre côté on est
aux intérêts de 35% sur 20
absolument l'ensemble de la production
d'époque qu'une expérience
monsieur gervais ottawa au fait quand
même un certain pas au printemps on a
modifié le programme de paiement
anticipé agricole là pour aider les
producteurs à faire face à
l'augmentation du coût des intrants et
de tous les coûts on s'entend est-ce que
c'est suffisant non c'est pas suffisant
la problématique est un programme de
paiement anticipé c'est pas toutes les
productions qui ont accès à ce programme
de paiements vélo justement certaines
productions et dans le corps des icônes
et l'économie de tirer un conseil qui
bien que le programme de paiement cip et
l'eau est pas suffisant pour compenser
l'impact et tarifs sur chacune des
entreprises agricoles sont concernés et
ce sont toutes les productions qui sont
concernés pas seulement certaines
productions mais quand vous demandez de
l'aide d'ottawa ce que vous aimeriez
tout simplement qu'on lève le tarif
douanier ou vous espérez un montant
on est ouvert aux deux possibilités que
ce soit un moment terre pour compenser
les agriculteurs ou la levée des petits
oiseaux y était commandée avant les
sanctions l'imposition des sanctions en
se resservant que les engrais ont été
imposées de tarifs alors ce que
l'extension et eni et le pétrole dans
certains corps puis des tarifs à payer
pour rentrer au canada et
cohérence bon évidemment c'est c'est un
problème qui s'ajoute à plusieurs autres
tout le monde vit l'inflation les
agriculteurs aussi qu'est ce qui pèse le
plus sur les finances des cultivateurs
en ce moment les fertilisants sait
quelque chose mais qu en est il du reste
je vous dirais les différents saisir ce
n'est pas qu'un porteur puisque
dépendamment de la rétive de natation et
du style de culture qu'un agriculteur
fait le coup des fertilisants cette
année le double au triple dépendamment
du voisin grec est requis les coûts de
l'énergie qui ont dernièrement
énormément aussi qu on est parfois
important au niveau des coûts
d'opération de la ferme parce que tout
ce que les frais afférents que ce soit
là les pièces de machinerie métiers des
services aux mécaniciens et les services
d'entretien
effectivement la super si beaucoup
monsieur gervais on comprend bien vous
demande merci d'avoir été là merci pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit